c'est un des trois véhicules à
l'hydrogène au québec
oui on a quelques dizaines sont les
routes au québec initialement quelques
dizaines gabriel antonius qui physicien
à lui qu tr se passionne pour tout ce
qui touche à l'hydrogène
ici on voit la pile à combustible donc
c'est là que l'hydrogène est convertie
en électricité pour recharger la
batterie et faire tourner le moteur
électrique car une voiture à l'hydrogène
c'est à toute fin pratique un véhicule
électrique
la différence c'est que pour une voiture
électrique traditionnelle toute
l'énergie doit être stockés avant de
partir alors que pour un véhicule comme
celui ci la batterie d'alimenter au fur
et à mesure par une bonbonne d'hydrogène
dans une voiture électrique à batterie
on va avoir besoin d'une batterie assez
lourde pour stocker suffisamment
d'énergie pour avoir une grande
autonomie
alors que dans une voiture à hydrogène
on peut se permettre d'avoir un plus
petites batteries plus légères
c'est pour ça qu'ils drainent est
particulièrement intéressant pour le
transport lourd comme des camions les
trains les avions des secteurs qui sont
très difficiles à électrifier parce
qu'il faudrait des batteries gigantesque
pour les faire avancer
mais quand on parle d'hydrogène il faut
faire attention aussi à la façon dont il
est produit
parce que oui d'hydrogène verts mais
aussi l'hydrogène qui fabriqué à partir
d'hydrocarbures et donc qui est moins
propre aujourd'hui au niveau mondial
vous avez 99% de l'hydrogène produit qui
est produit à partir de ressources
fossiles comme par exemple du gaz
naturel au québec par contre on innove à
bécancour l'entreprise air liquide vient
de se doter de ces quatre grosses
machines des électrolyseurs qui lui
permettent de produire une quantité
industrielle d'hydrogène à partir d'eau
on va séparer en définitive dans ces
modules l'oxygène d'une part l'hydrogène
d'autre part et on utilise de
l'hydroélectricité est une énergie
propre pour casser les molécules de
l'hydrogène qu'on va produire est un
hydrogène qu'on peut vraiment qualifié
de totalement renouvelable
ça veut dire effectivement y'a pas
d'émanations dioxyde de carbone
supplémentaire cet hydrogène preuve peut
ensuite servir pour le transport mais
aussi pour décarbonés le secteur
industriel qui est un grand consommateur
d'hydrogène évolution des technologies
nous permettent réellement d'envisager
aujourd'hui d'aller vers un monde zéro
carbone d'aller vers une décarbonisation
progressive de notre